let's say we have two banks bank a
and bank b and you might already know
that banks all banks lend out the great
majority of the money that they get in
as deposits but they keep some of the
money as reserves one just in case their
depositors come say hey can i have some
of my money back and two because the
central bank the federal reserve says
you have to keep a certain amount of
your of your deposits in reserve there
is a reserve requirement but you could
imagine over the course of doing
transactions thousands of transactions a
day millions maybe maybe bank b more of
its depositors come by and say hey give
me some of my deposits back and
obviously he's lent out a lot of that
money so he starts running low on
reserves maybe bank a the depositors
haven't asked for the money for whatever
reason bank a sitting on a lot of cash
so in this situation what you're going
to have happen is bank a is going to
lend some reserves is going to lend some
cash to bank b so this is
lending some cash and they will charge
an interest rate for lending that cash
maybe it'll be
five percent interest and that won't be
five percent per day and usually these
loans are on a per day basis and then
the next day it'll be renegotiated on a
per day basis but it's not five percent
per day it'll be five percent
per year so it'll be much some much
smaller fraction but usually as i
mentioned this lending takes place on a
per day basis so we'll say hey this is
your cash for just tonight if you need
if you need it for the next night we'll
talk again and maybe it'll be another
five percent or maybe the interest rate
can change again
now let's say that the federal reserve
is sitting over here and for whatever
reason wants to stimulate the economy so
this is the fed and they want to
stimulate the economy so they start
printing some money
they i should do money in green
so the federal reserve here is start
printing
they're starting to print some money and
they want to do two things they want to
inject this money into the banking
system which essentially hopefully will
find its way into the economy and they
also want to lower the interest rate
especially the short-term interest rate
this overnight
borrowing remember this is the annual
interest rate but this is an overnight
loan
over
overnight learns so when i talk about
the short term interest rate i'm talking
about the interest rate on loans that
are made over very short periods of time
so what the federal reserve will do is
what's called open market operations
they will go
to the market maybe directly to these
banks or some other banks and they will
buy treasuries they will give this money
into the market and in exchange they
will usually buy treasury securities
sometimes something slightly different
but usually very safe securities and
maybe temporarily buy i'll talk about
repurchase agreements in the future and
what happens is that this cash goes in
the hands of the people who just sold
the treasury securities and they have to
deposit it in banks and so they might
deposit it in this bank over here they
might deposit it in this bank over here
or other banks but the net net effect is
that there's more cash now in the
banking system and if there's more cash
in the banking system this this guy
right over here needs less
this guy needs less cash so it lowers
demand it lowers the demand for cash and
then this guy has more to give so it
raises supply
raises the supply because some people
maybe just took some of this cash and
deposit with them so if it raises the
supply of cash and this guy needs it
less then the rate to borrow this cash
is going to go down
so maybe instead of 5
it goes down to 4
so what that would do is it would lower
the short term of the yield curve the
short end of the yield curve so let me
draw a yield curve right over here so
this is maturity
on this axis
maturity and this is yield and let's say
that the yield curve before looked like
this
let's say it looked like this where this
right over here is five percent and this
is overnight
overnight this might be the yield on i
don't know one year debt
this might be the yield on i don't know
maybe it's five year debt
whatever i could keep going but by doing
this open market operation the fed was
able to do both of its goals it was able
to inject cash printed cash into the
economy and it's also able to lower the
interest rate so it took it from being
five percent down to four percent so now
because of this open market operation
the fed the yield curve might start to
look something like that